but first up he is a Pulitzer
prize-winning historian whose latest
book is the soul of America the battle
for our better angels Jon Meacham good
and I just want to say first of all a
lot of people know you from TV now but
you also write books apparently I do in
my spare time I see I bet you a lot of
people are not that sure about that but
I want to tell you if you like Jon beat
you're on TV read his books
this guy is an amazing writer and the
book is called soul of America right my
first question do we still have one we
do really important we do because but
the soul in full disclosure is an idea
that's not about what's just best about
us Socrates all the way through the
Hebrew and the Greek always argued that
the soul was the essence of life it was
breath and so in the American soul for
instance it's not just that oh fourth of
July
everything's great the soul of the
country has room for dr. King but it
also has room for the clan and every era
is determined by which of those two
forces wins out and see here's the thing
the clan didn't used to be this close to
the White House that's why I worry about
your they did optimism no it did and I
am optimistic well know what in the
modern era yes Andrew Johnson certainly
was a Klansman well in 1925 you had
50,000 Klansmen marching down
Pennsylvania Avenue without wearing
their masks you had Calvin Coolidge
wasn't sympathetic to them no but the
Democratic National Convention in 1924
had 347 Klansmen who were delegates you
had an immense Wow is that right you had
four million I feel better okay you had
you had four
you tell me am other bad [ __ ] about
America yeah now I know you were on the
air in 1866 I think it was cable access
then yes okay the Dumont but you had a
president who was against the 14th and
15th amendments who by the way got
impeached so we can we can talk about
that in Andrew Johnson you had in if
we've been talking in 1919 1920 you had
Woodrow Wilson who resegregate of the
federal government who cracked down and
400 newspapers who disagreed with him
and who launched it launched his
Attorney General to for non probable
cause raids all across America but they
were reflecting feelings in the country
that were much more prevalent than they
are today
I don't think about the Klan about race
well the Klan was a read the second Klan
in the 1920s was a reflection see if the
sounds somewhat familiar they were
worried about a changing economy they
were worried about the culture shifting
on them they were worried about
demographic changes they were worried
about immigration
there was a governor of Georgia who was
a member of the Klan who called for
guess what building a wall of steel to
keep immigrants out so if you want if
you look at 1920s it's too far back to
look at this alright let's go to the
1950s for four years Joe McCarthy
terrorized America he did so with the
help in many cases of the press the
Hearst Newspapers were kind of a Fox
News of the era in the 1920s one out of
every four Americans read the Hearst
Newspapers
and Hearst supported McCarthy it was a
very few voices against McCarthy early
on a woman Margaret chase Smith who was
the Republican senator from Maine came
out against him early it took the men as
usual four years to catch up but what we
ended up man always an applause break
I'm sorry what and again I'm not mr.
Rogers on c-span here I'm not arguing
that everything is always great but the
point is in my lifetime in your lifetime
in my native region of the south we had
apartheid women have not voted in this
country for quite a century yet right we
are not yet at the third anniversary is
coming up next month of the marriage
equality decision American history is by
fits and starts has tended to get better
why is it gotten better not just because
of presidents but not just because of
the Congress but the cause of protests
and resistance and people saying the
country we want is not the country that
closes its fist it's one that opens its
arm but here's the difference
in the cases you cite I mean Joe
McCarthy was censured by the Senate
right four years in okay Senate's not
gonna censure Trump they love Trump I
mean what's frightening now to me is
that the Republican Party has so quickly
lined up behind this fascist and they're
in on it and I think that's a
fundamental difference and I also think
it's it's a it's a flaw that the
founders did not seem oh I think the
founders saw all this coming you think
they saw Donald Trump coming and I think
they I think they would have been
stunned that it took this goddamn long
for us to get one the whole Constitution
was and how do you think we're gonna get
one I think
one by I think a pretty wave election in
the midterm I think the courts and the
rule of law is gonna prevail and I think
the people themselves and this is not a
populist argument on the other side but
how did we break down Jim Crow how did
we break down functional apartheid
people how did womens get the right to
vote they protested they stood up they
had conversations like this and
ultimately those better angels did
prevail to the point where what is the
immigration issue in this country the
immigration issue is that people want to
come here
so for all the having a Mad King which
we do who as I've said to you before if
he knew who King Lear was it would be
like King Lear for all of that if you
have enough of these forces the people
the press the Congress which is as you
say not in great shape right now or the
presidency the courts if you have enough
of those forces working then we will
under live the crisis yeah but I don't
know if we do I mean we definitely don't
have the Congress you would know you
talk about a wave election yes we could
impeach him I think the Democrats will
take the house this it's don't get it
don't get giddy because no I'm sorry I
have to be the skunk at the garden party
here but yeah but done well with that
but
yeah yeah somebody has to
somebody has to yeah thank you but this
is let me say the skunk point yeah
even if we win the wave election that's
that's the house they will impeach him
then you need 67 senators to convict or
else he's there Clinton was impeached he
stayed there now you have a wounded
animal but not that wounded because
he'll just say fake news he's more of a
martyr than ever you know that his
approval ratings went up this week I did
the crazier reacts I'm not worried about
a Mad King we've had presidents who
didn't know [ __ ] before I'm worried
about someone who wants to be a dictator
I mean look at this read his statement
for the review this time from this week
on the Justice Department a rigged
system this is his own Justice
Department did any other president talk
like this about their own Justice
Department why such an unequal justice
at some point I will have no choice but
to use the powers granted to the
presidency and get involved well first
of all I don't think he doesn't know
there's no Azhar no he doesn't know he
thinks he's a king I mean that's a
direct threat is that if he can get off
Twitter into Google he might find yeah I
wouldn't hold your breath for that
is there a precedent for that for a
president warring on his own Justice
Department the way he does his own FBI
this deep state talk we hear about the
hid way if you listen to the Nixon tapes
yeah
and Nixon was convinced that the press
it's the press was against him that
these Justice Department he had the
Saturday night other similarities there
are similarities
except he went but guess what there's
this fabled moment everybody talks about
how Barry Goldwater went to the White
House you guys don't remember you know
what date that was August 7th very quick
the next day 26 months into the
Watergate scandal right Barry Goldwater
left public life with a very high
profile but it took about 20 again John
what was the message that they were
bringing to President Nixon the message
they were bringing was you have lost the
support of the Republicans in Congress
right that is not a message anyone can
deliver right now to this president not
right now but what do we know chiefly
about politicians that they want to be
reelected right they are more far more
often mirrors and moulders of public and
that's what's so scary that's why they
won't turn on him because the base loves
him and they know that that he has a
connection with their voters that they
do not that's true but you have to
change those hearts and minds and among
the people but you know I do guess what
Joe McCarthy's approval rating was after
the have you no decency sir no 34% you
can get 34% the country to say damn near
anything right this is a battle about
the 20 percent who either aren't paying
enough attention who are beginning to be
worried about the fact that Rudy
Giuliani after for a pretty clearly
liquid dinner the other night
something Anthony Trollope used to say
that he dined freely that you have to
get to the 20 percent who are accessible
by in the my whole argument in this
again is not that everything is going to
be a fairy tale it never is there was
never a once upon a time and there's
never never a happily ever after but you
can get because you did it with women's
suffrage you did it with civil rights we
did it ultimately with the you
of the country we've done it with issues
not not this I don't see him leaving
under any condition including people
knocking on the door with guns that he'd
be Scarface he'd be watching on the
security camera
say hello to my little friend okay I'm
badgered you I don't you think he sent
Jared a house yes all right it's a great
book
thank you for trying to cheer me
[Applause]